can a photo get you to buy a handbag a
pair of shoes or a dress guilt think so
the e-retailer is giving the traditional
stock photo a makeover hoping that
though worthy shoots will lose their
selves we don't have the network of
physical stores all around the world and
all around the country and so you put a
lot into this one location located in
the Brooklyn Navy Yard guilt studio is
where each item's guilt cells is styled
photographs and edited before it hits
the company's web store front every day
thousands of books are coming in we're
shooting those products and we're
getting them out the door 150 people
work at gilts photo lab in 2013 they
shot 170,000 products and retouched
540,000 images I almost feel like I'm on
a magazine shoot do you see a difference
in how your things cells that are shot
by a certain photographer or if you have
them worn by a model or you don't Oh
completely we'll shoot it one way and
see how it sells shoot another way see
how it sells
gilt moved into this empty warehouse
when they launched in 2007 since then
the amount of space has grown from the
size of a walk-in closet to the size of
a football field what makes the
difference to the consumer yeah I think
it's just that ed that's styling so much
of fashion is styling so my favorite
room in all of guilt is the room I'm
going to take you into right now this is
bigger than my first apartment I you
know why is all this year the stylist
will take given products you come in
here and say what shoes would be
interesting do we need a jacket what
about a necklace and bracelet earrings
how do we make that red dress
interesting and beautiful and how do we
make it pop is it an overwhelming
expense for you this is not a big
expense for us this is a luxury to make
sure that they go customer knows have
made things fresh and interesting and
styled in a different way oh and to grow
the six hundred million dollars in
luxury purchases they had last year